I have a question but so I got put in a
bear hug by a big guy this is a grown
man I was in New York and you get my
drink cold I was in New York this guy
named Gary
um has been showing up my shows
he picked me up Roman yeah I picked me
up um and just shook me and I couldn't
get him off me and I want to figure out
how to deal with that stuff he's coming
to my shows and he said he's coming to
my shows I have shows this weekend in
Nyack at Levity Live he's going to go to
briantown.com and get tickets I don't
know if it's coming to Thursday Friday
Saturday show but I know it's going to
be another toss-up hold on so you have
to pass the pits there yeah you shake
your baby he's like oh what's up Brian
yeah and then he picked me up started
shaking me around he's like yes yes oh
yeah I can't wait for your show yeah
yeah
he wasn't doing that it's crazy
be serious I'm serious no I'm dizzy and
I'm dizzy too grab me again
I gotta be here right away right away
but but you're not expecting them but
what if what if you go for it here yeah
but see now if you grab your hands I'm
screwed right you wouldn't swim on your
arms then boom now we're over under high
school wrestling yeah yeah what's up
they're here yeah yeah
um you know yes yes get off me yeah yeah
problem yes problem Gary Gary stop sorry
I got so pissed off I don't know I can't
tell you're upset about it okay that
works so swim one of my arms in and then
yeah and you like that so when you're
here I know this is about you and I'm
trying to help out I'm really nervous
he's gonna come to Tacoma
he's not gonna come
you're right that's all right I'm paying
my turn okay oh what's that stupid old
[__]
let's go
well now don't let him do that don't let
them get high
don't don't let me just win on your face
you know what
they come back
hey sweet match we're gonna bring you
Couture's High School
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
come on now let me get us over the top
dude let me tell you something right now
you wore green again
uh I wore green again I'm in a good mood
me too but I'm in a good mood because of
this
I wanted to say this to anybody
struggling with cancer oh God oh my God
my friend my friend was diagnosed with
multiple myeloma four and a half years
ago it was a bad prognosis
she did this experimental therapy four
years a half years later they were like
hey this is the last resort she gets in
these trials where'd she go she got in
her numbers were so bad they were like
you know what let's give this a shot
it worked so well they called her up
they were like listen we can't find any
trace of cancer in your body
these new therapies that are coming
about because of Technology that's
moving at an exponential rate if you're
sick get positive because they're coming
up with [__] in real time that's
actually Curative I mean how long it's
really quiet how long huh but how long
Leo worry about Pfizer and the
pharmaceutical companies no what's crazy
profit on it but some of those things
are making a fortune I mean some of
those things are making money but
they're also like really working right
because this thing is essentially
getting it's it's a they figured out a
way to get her help her T Cell to be a
Super T Cell they do this weird thing in
a lab and then they should and then it
teaches your other T cells how to be
super T cells so it kills it actually
your own immune system kills the the the
cancer
and just say it worked right it worked
it sounds worse when you break it down I
know I don't biologists no I don't
believe it we're all broken we're all
the super oh
got no yeah and I don't know anything so
who are you doing this for I know this
yeah but how many people have opinions
about viruses and everything else no
dude the virus hey hey you yeah are a
[__] comedian yeah we all do this
yeah I have a joke about that like
vegans they annoy me a little bit
because they come from cities usually in
their upper class you know uh there's no
white people from from mesh ball and
cities you know not but you have strong
opinions about farming yeah you'd have
never met a farmer never never work with
your hands and I I suffer from the same
issue I got you know I do all I got
plenty of opinions this bro bro science
is fun that's what makes podcasting well
you can get away with it here my
favorite thing of course is to take a
non-fighter who knows nothing and
explain why disgusting somebody's really
good at disgusting and I'll start going
on well his eye the way he lines his eye
up where his feet are well it's like I
don't really know what it's like you and
Tom Tom who books our show Tom knows
fighting too yes and I told Tom I go Hey
Thomas it's always right so if you want
to talk about fighting take by another
group chat I said do you notice I don't
participate when Brian's in there
because he's like marab's gonna be Peter
Yan I said I would bet any amount of
money rob Molly watts and you went no
come on and I I text Tom I go hey
Brandon know who morab is so when you
add that to the group chat this you're
literally wasting your debts oh I'm
doing good Peter's better you and Peter
come on his takedown defense on okay
yeah then I watched that guy and then I
was like oh yeah you just don't know
yeah he's a [__] monster God monster
my God and also doesn't seem to get
tired at all I mean how do you deal with
the guys constantly trying to take you
down she didn't have some questions on
that but that's Shin not me what are the
questions don't I'm just saying like
he's just skeptical I'm not saying he is
I'm just saying he looked like he was
such in good shape that he was like a
guy that would be on EPO but he's not
I'm just saying that's a comp that's how
good he was I mean you know the guy the
guy those those dudes are they just take
training a different to a different
level oh yeah
yeah but he came up wrestling and
fighting uh since he was probably what
seven I mean who knows but still the
training's training right but the
Russians don't
do that stuff
oh yeah
yeah chin just had little skeptical
hippo eyes that's fair no I'm definitely
not dissing anybody who comes out of Ray
language Camp [__] that no why would you
just love those guys yeah they kick you
around you're [__] I love right but
also no listen he's just a beast look
Covington doesn't get Time Boom Kobe
Covington doesn't get tired he keeps
going he's he his cardio is out of
control why are you what what are you
doing I'm with you insane okay
come on yeah come on that's a whole
different level and does it run or can't
run can't run
over him got busted for PDS you believe
that [__]
I love it his team's like we deny these
things when did this happen recently
well yeah like yesterday got busted in
his win against batahari also why are
they testing for steroids in glory
especially when ovarim's 44 years old
what did you think was gonna happen
you signed the for the ubering he
delivered you got the Uber him he won
the fight what are you doing testing
this man yeah I don't what kind of
shenanigan [__] is this butahari's
got to be 45 now neither of them are
young no
he was but why test these guys
38 okay
he's a rough cat he's got he's like some
guy in the slap Fight League got uh
busted for cocaine it's like hold on oh
wait wait
I thought that was promoted I thought
when you signed the contract comes with
meth and cocaine to slap each other
isn't that what this is isn't that what
we're doing it's not what we're doing
why would you test those guys what the
[__] are you doing
I don't know I I didn't know Glory
tested that's weird especially out there
especially uh an older Overeem it just
doesn't make a ton of sense it doesn't
make a lot it doesn't make a ton of
sense don't make ton of sense at all I'm
just I'm outraged are you caught up on
Last of Us no no season finale we can't
even talk about George United I watch a
full swing about Pro Golfing okay and
yeah I I I don't want to be able I asked
you if you watched
The Last of Us not some boring [__] dude
God damn it's golf dude Pro Golf you
don't play golf no
no I hate golf I hate golf I'll tell you
something else
I don't like the fans of golf I'm not I
don't like anything about golf I know
it's really hard but it's a mental game
those guys at the top you play all the
time well you you play against 156 other
guys and then you're in in a big
tournament yeah if you make three
mistakes you're [__] it's Pro Sports
it's more than a sport it's a skill set
it's a weird skill set it's a sport for
sure the mental thing for sure I told
you when I was doing that charity golf
tournament and they had Bubba Watson
there right when he won the Masters wow
they had to he would only do it that to
fly him in on a private helicopter
because he lives in Florida yeah so they
flew in private helicopter playing at
TBC Sawgrass which is like legendary I
had no business playing golf there I
[__] up the course sure so they've I
everyone's like oh my God wind
everywhere he lands on uh the whole nine
and he's you know he's ready go he's
like you know [__] he's off I was like
that's a goddamn American right there he
waves everybody they hand him a club he
goes like this no warm nothing how's
everyone just eating [__] he's on
hunk yeah Kink right next to the hole
probably like he's been doing it I was
like and he's like this is back on the
helicopter what really oh that's that
three millionth time he's done it see
guys hilarious well I I get a kick when
you're watching these guys and they're
about to tee off and they're hitting at
300 yards there are people there's a
corridor of people watching if that guy
slices that ball you're losing your eye
or your life I know what about people
all the way down it's unbelievable the
floor yeah like you can get [__] like
the people have got [__] up from golf
ball my buddy got [__] up John rank is
everybody he got hit in the tournament
right in the head knocked out knocked
out got back up there you got to go no
I'm okay kept going he had complications
yeah man I mean it's a straight up ball
flying through the goddamn air yeah it's
not it's no joke it's like those houses
are nice along the golf course bro I can
sign up and play my dad saw a teenager
who's I in a golf course hit him in the
eye
that's the story
okay now I've always told that story as
we're talking you know it's coming out
of your mouth did he lose his eye no
yeah yeah in the face could have been in
the eye did he lose it I mean I guess if
it hit you hard enough what happened did
I come out yeah
follow him in the hospital did you
follow up on the retinal scans because
I've seen what it takes to lose an eye
my boy visiting last night from a
[__] roundhouse from East toward
Belfor on all the sauce in the world
yeah a golf ball but your dad probably
says that word of caution right scare
you a little bit scary a little bit uh
my girl is watching that 600 pound life
on TV and Tiger goes oh my god daddy
look at look at her arms I go she eats
too much candy
here's why you know she eats all the
candy buddy all candy and fast food
that's all she does all day you say if I
eat faster I'm like I'm not saying it's
gonna happen yeah but there's a lane you
can go down my father you want
McDonald's still he's like no didn't
think so talking to my dad today I hear
Norris in the back of my words I'm in
the gym I go you're in the gym you and
he goes yeah why I go what are you doing
in the gym he goes I'm selling candy
it's a good joke candy he goes yeah
these people look like they're gonna use
some energy they're all old it's good
good job that's funny very good joke
um
do you watch the Oscars at all no I
don't I don't watch uh anything I'm not
invited to it hurts our feelings I take
my ball and I go home and I've never
watched the Oscars because it's a weird
thing I've never been invited to the
Oscars because my career didn't get
there so [__] the awesome but
99.99 what's that actors aren't gonna
make oh that doesn't matter to me yeah
see I tend to uh see
the fact that I not a great dancer not a
great piano player not a great guitarist
I went to hadestown I went into that
Broadway show and the fact that I can't
write that way sing that way and play
music that way ruins my day so you're
like no I go I go I love it I love it
but part of me dies that I can't beat
everything all at once I feel you don't
you feel that way when you see something
great and you're like I want to be able
to sing like that or I want to be on a
piano like that no no no that's my
problem I appreciate it you're a bit
you're a hater
yeah now if I could do it all over again
a couple things I do
plan instrument
learn how to dance really well
be broke right get a black belt in Jiu
Jitsu yep you'd be broke yeah keep going
what's funny about no these things are
making money what's the funny thing
about everything in life is let's be
honest with me if I really trained in
Jiu Jitsu yeah and I've been training
for 15 20 years did you make it 30. okay
yeah you're going and I wrestled in
college which I should have done I'm
pissed it I didn't do okay okay I've
gone through four years of wrestling
College
you and I [__] around on that mat yeah
what happens what do you mean what
happens
we like really go at your age we're
really gone I have a lot of skill I'm
gonna beat you down like the bully Gary
same thing yeah whatever I want same
thing whatever yeah it's gonna hurt your
feelings it doesn't matter if you've
dedicated your whole life to this and
it's gonna you're gonna you're gonna
break me quickly maybe the same speed
I'm gonna [__] you maybe the same time
yeah because I'm only 30 out there I
know you're right I never go full no of
course not no but then if you have the
skill and the experience I can't hold
back and I'm going out because then you
might you you're gonna have my good
position yeah
so then I'm going to get then I'm going
to get full full bore Brandon that's a
big problem it's a problem that's a
problem because full board Brennan black
belt Jiu Jitsu 270. yeah no that's a
problem well I'm not 270. probably
though right no no you're close on no no
what are we at with all this yeah
probably 50s that's not true
I hate to say it I always tell people
that they always walk away about 2 30 I
go that's adorable that you said that
definitely that's adorable not 2 30. if
he dieted super hard to be through
you're talking about a lot of bone 2 30.
you have very thick bones yeah 230 if I
was like well you're trim shrunk you're
very true oh yeah you are not fat at all
I don't know if you have that much more
fat on your body than I do I'm
intermittent fasting so I don't eat till
you're you're you're you're as lean as
you get for a big guy I've never seen
you ever in my life with you know maybe
maybe sometimes you get a little bit of
a tummy a little bit of a uh but that's
more from probably eating like wheat or
something yeah you bloated I'll get
bloated but I don't see fat no you know
you know I have a lot handles no so I'd
kill myself yeah but you don't so so
what I'm saying is what I'm saying is
Daddy's 270. Daddy's in natural resting
oh yeah 265. and if don't be surprised
don't be coming off the road on Mondays
270 270 275 don't be surprised yeah it's
a real yeah that's a if Daddy gets a
little too loosey-goosey and things go
south for me and that's a big secret
Papa's 300 pounds easy one bad Breakaway
from 300 and you carry it and be
hilarious yeah 300 but 270 you're moving
pretty quick not bad and and and and
also you've been lifting your whole life
so it's a different kind of density
dance yeah Dance I'm like a pound cake
you're I'm just you're strong strong
your girl name something thicker than a
pound cake a gorilla boy gorilla boy I
saw you I knew you were very strong when
I saw you toss up a giant black belt
Samoan that's what I noticed when I went
[Music]
they don't get fat they don't get left
handles really but that's when I
realized you're Samoan I'm Simone yes my
mom
something happened your both your
parents are not small people no and I
think you get most of your power
and your ferocity I don't know your
dad's pretty tough but your dad's more
long and thin thin he's standing but
he's a barrel chested guy he's a big boy
now yeah big boy 100 Cherokee yeah 100
Cherokee or Blackfoot Indian they were
very big people and that's how facts
it's adorable that he says mom sell it
he couldn't be more Native American and
I mean he's pure Native American if you
look at his family tree it goes back and
it stops here in this country maybe his
ancestors came over the Bering Strait
but he's 100 straight Native American
whatever the man whatever the myth is
with Native American where they came
from something he came from there so he
comes from a long line of cheese
can we take a break yeah dude take a
break I'm gonna be in Tacoma I beat you
too I'm in Tacoma next Thursday Friday
Saturday Tacoma Tacoma Washington March
23rd and 25th you dress like Teddy
weather I'm sure March 23rd to the 25th
Atlanta uh April 13th to the 15th kid
show take that thick boy.com you're
gonna mean West Nyack right I'll be in
West Nyack this weekend I hope that
bully don't show up dude man Gary I'm
worried about it I I but I know what to
do now physically uh Levity Live
Thursday 16 March 17th so for Thursday
Friday Saturday and then I got my
goobies at the end of the month that
doesn't matter good club look I I
sometimes you get injured dude an injury
sucks hate them the pain the hospital
bills everything sometimes you're
missing words well you have no money you
can go to the worst you can get ruined
that way you know you've been injured
hiring a lawyer could be the best
decision you'll ever make yeah I know a
lot of you expensive hiring the Lord is
crazy confusing but Morgan and Morgan
actually makes it super easy how easy
bro how easy with Morgan Morgan you can
start a claim from your couch in about
six clicks six clicks from my phone yeah
I want to call that's okay you can
simply text I don't have money lawyers I
don't have money it's too expensive and
the best part is it's free dude free you
only pay if you win your case Morgan
Morgan America's largest injury Law Firm
yeah but how many lawyers
900 900 lawyers 100 offices 24 7
customer service staff they recovered
over 15 billion dollars 15 million 15
billion dude billion all you have to do
is dial pound law or go to
forthepeople.com fighter that's Dow
pound law or for the people.com fighter
that's thou pound law or for the
people.com fighter this is a paid
advertisement this is a paid
advertisement ah man
increase my
my face is nice and clean but my brain
Dusty my brain you need some Alpha Brain
but I don't think just regular Alpha
Brain which they've sold over a million
bottles the best nootropic on the planet
Earth what if I tell you a little
something about Alpha Brain Black Label
Daddy tell me more dude it's Alpha Brain
on the good stuff really it's extra
Alpha Brain if you want your normal
Alpha Brain you have Alpha Brain instant
you just put an eight ounce of water
Alpha Brain Focus shot which I
absolutely love get you right to the
point right they have shroom Tech
protein powders Fitness Gear streaming
Fitness you can save 10 off by going to
audit.com
f-a-t-k all right that's on it.com
f-a-t-k for the best nootropics on the
planet including Alpha Brain Black 10
off you're welcome now let's get back to
the program I want my goddamn
reparations let's take a look at him
though that's a Native American
okay
that's a bad picture of him I don't like
that picture of him but he's a he's a
big striking man now look at him look at
the size of your dad look at his size
your dad that's not a small guy no no
that's so you got that side and then you
got uh then you got Gigante look at dad
with the mustache look at Jay look at
Jay and look at you the young gay twink
yeah
Daddy's a lot was my stepfather very hot
your stepmom's hot dad is just a big
mustachioed man what's the worst dad
loves his boy he looks like he says the
worst weed in Denver right there doesn't
he Jay looks like like the budding young
athlete that became David Blaine
that's impressive dude I look identical
to Tiger there oh yeah what's that Jesus
Christ that looks like tiger yeah to a
team yeah man look at you do you have a
soft Twinkie face that's great but uh I
would never have looked to you and said
that kid's going to grow into a giant
monster no
yeah yeah yeah yeah but then Mom but Mom
is where you get your other it's it was
The Perfect Storm you know just they had
to have a heavy weight
they had to have would Jay fight at 205
could he suck down to 205 I think he
could yeah he's like 220 now yeah he
could be he could be a 205. he could
even be an 85. crazy yeah but at the end
s kids yeah but Jay's big boy you think
you cut down to 135
um I think I think I would have to
I think I would have to do you think
he'd fight at 115
no [__] off but I I think I could get
down to 35. I'm 170 now
I mean sugar Shawn it walks around at
165. he's not you know he's thin but his
leg's an ass yeah yeah he's not a big
boy no but I'm we're I'm I might be an
installer might be I don't think I am
and I'm and I I might be
I don't think I'm thicker I've I've no
no no rolled around with him no no
everybody's yeah so I'd have to fight a
35. hey real quick what'd you give me
for my birthday
look at that Saturday look at this look
at that old [__] I look like Satan
what you do look old there yeah you
think you look like Satan and Suga
doesn't there yeah I
love sugar
um
yeah I hope what did you get me for my B
date though oh dude it's your birthday
Saturdays on the 18th
40. I know the big 4-0 I've known you
since you were 26. yeah wow yeah right
yeah can you see when the ultimate
fighter with season 14 big country was
season 14 season 14.
the new season should start pretty soon
here December 3rd 2011. now hold on but
I Met You in 2000 well that's well
that's what 2010. so hold on yeah
because December 3rd 2011 that's when it
aired I met you we filmed seven years
old are you sure maybe 26 season 14 says
Biz being Miller Oh weird uh
see it was 15.
I'll just do heavyweights no no I don't
do that it wasn't Shane Carwin yeah
alternate Fire season Shane Carwin
uh Roy Nelson
2012 dude
that's 2012 so well it aired September I
know but they filmed 2011. oh yeah or
maybe 2000 yeah 2011 so I met you in
2011.
that's nuts
2012 it says September 2012. yeah that's
when it was released though yeah yeah
way before
so that was well
yeah
that's so nuts yes
one who brought me in there that's right
right
that's so insane it's where I first met
Bang Ludwig all those guys and that was
uh that was that was embarrassing
walking in there with all those with all
those athletes I was like oh geez what
am I going to say to these guys you're
there to make them laugh though yeah
what you did but um man yeah we had a
good time that was fun it was a hot
second ago yeah now they're bringing
Ultimate Fighter back
I feel like it's into a little better
you know it's been just in the dumps
it's gonna do better with Conor yeah 27
dude
I met Jimmy Burke when he was 30 he's
61. damn yeah he's 61.
and do you see Jimmy when you're in New
York we haven't talked about New York I
was in New York awesome uh Sony Hall is
a theater you got to do we should do it
together do a fine kid there we should
do it together it's a great great venue
is it cool yeah where's it at in
Manhattan right on Broadway right right
where Broadway Theater districts 47th
and like Broadway oh in the heart of it
oh dude the mix yeah literally
unbelievable you had a good time out
there I had a great time going right
back you saw everybody and uh did Dove
open opened
my wife goes my wife and my my openers
Kevin Mack and and uh and Nick uh
Simmons what a four-man show uh no it
was actually Kevin didn't do it it was
just Nick because I didn't know Kevin
would be in New York so it was just Nick
and dub so Nick was a host that's enough
yeah and and I've got Dove gets up he
goes yeah I'll do like I don't know 10
minutes I go 10 minutes I go no you're
doing 25 to 30. get up there and do a
second oh yeah but I'm like you're here
yeah I you know I wanted the audience to
see what he was and is he getting up a
lot of the sellers my wife and my the
other the other my guys who opened they
were like they looked at me they were
like yeah because he's so smart and
they're like he's a Monster yeah and my
wife was like oh my God I go yeah that
stuff David off Monster that stuff David
the best yeah yeah he's in Aruba right
now doing doing stand-up really yeah but
he has no social media games he's so bad
at it none it broke my heart when he got
on there too I'm like oh dude this ain't
you I can do that tell thing don't get
on there he's just he can't do it it's
just not for certain people do it yeah
he tries did you guys hang out after the
show yeah well he had to he had to go he
was a little bit but he had to run
because uh uh he was going to Aruba in
the morning did you take pictures with
him or nothing
I did take a no maybe not oh wow I'm the
worst you'd think that I had this whole
place filled Sony Hall no it's a theater
no pictures and did I take any pictures
this is why I saw a higher photographer
no that's why I'm a piece of [__] and I
and there's not photographers in
Manhattan New York and I was like what
am I doing like why am I doing this to
myself I could connect you with the
homeless pamper works with the Stefano
to film it all he did all my [__] maybe
he's available for Nyack I'm gonna be
there this weekend
maybe let's pass on West Nyack right
well it's only 30 minutes outside of New
York City though yeah maybe I'll pass
not Sony Hall I had a I forgot
I had a crazy heckler
really yes I forgot to tell you so I'm
talking about my son I have this whole
bit about my son
and this guy starts I hear him shouting
I look down
and he's like you do a tool to have a
baby you are too old to have a baby you
are too old and there's whole table's
like this now I got my nephews with 20
of their boys
yeah and they're my nephews are not
passive dudes they're all college
go up so I can hear my nephew going
boy shut the [__] up
because he's from England but also
you're from here yeah there's this whole
thing going on I'm like all right all
right I got to settle this it was that
loud you're too old
and I I can see he's a mess something's
going on I don't know what's up oh
clearly and I go you're being an ageist
AHS and I said no no listen you you
should know that baby you're not good
and it makes no sense because yeah she's
kicking me under the table I don't care
and his wife is just like that she's
like this so something's going on he's
having a moment or maybe he can't have a
kid I don't know he's about 30 and 32
and he was having I think what he had
was a an episode I don't know so nobody
would do that he was dead serious I
think maybe it's his insecurity maybe
his him and his girl try to have a baby
he can't yeah so he's triggered maybe
he's triggered but he was a fan I could
tell he was there to see me and he um
was he drunk I got him to kind of start
smiling and I think what happened was
maybe he has a man he had a manic
episode
and also maybe he was overwhelmed
sometimes guys get overwhelmed they want
to be part of something they don't know
they're like they're like I want to do
that but I don't know how to do that it
might just be an [__] I don't think
so I think he was not well I think
something was going on because I could
tell but he's really cool but people
table wasn't trying to interfere the
table was doing this their hands were
here they were very tense at the table
so something was up
maybe he's a [__] gangster I don't
know yeah there's something going on you
know what I mean what ethnicity was he
something probably close to like Russian
of some kind because your accent was
very
yeah it was something it was an accent
from a culture you don't [__] with
interesting right Harry if it's if he's
our no but handsome kind of Darker but
if he's if he's Georgian if he's uh if
he's from
Armenian
I do but some cultures like I don't know
if he is a if he's uh something was up
with him because his table was scared of
him but I got him I want him over I kind
of want him over because it made no
sense he was doing that so I knew he was
probably having an episode and he needed
my attention and he didn't light him up
I didn't light him up because there was
no EV there was no upside to lighting up
a guy like that I'll light you up if
you're being a dick and you're a jerk
this guy was having to acknowledge Him
what do you say oh I had I stopped
everything and I see in my opinion
sometimes with a Heckler like that you
have to stop and you have to see them
and you have to connect with them and
you have to figure out what's going on
sometimes yeah keep going that's
different I come to the Theo Rogan yeah
I make fun of them light them up and
then usually that does it we're like no
problem that's how this goes no problem
until you have somebody who seems to be
not in their right mind at that moment I
think I might have had a ball on this
job something so I was like I'm gonna
talk to this guy I don't wanna well he's
lucky the young Bros full of them yeah I
didn't want that because if he had got
boners yes he's gotten crazy yeah I had
20 30 dudes who were going to cause a
problem
and then I would have had to get in
there and do my my [__] and if I do my
[__] bro
if I start popping a man jumps off stage
don't let Dove get in there
in the fight in Texas
the whole thing popped off because the
guy was talking to him and then Dove
jumps out there and and hit the guy
right in the face pop pop twice like
that I mean
crazy who fights guys like us not you
because you're too big and there's no
upside yeah the problem with you is you
can't do anything to anybody because you
lose they'd have to really be asking for
it well they'd have to storm the stage
yeah
I think if somebody's doing come on down
if you storm the stage I'm gonna swing
yeah I have to I'm not sorry
I'm gonna swing yeah because I'm afraid
then I think you're oh yeah
yeah no I'm not gonna let you get the
job but outside that one crazy ass New
York is good the best I went and saw
Hades town
what's that it won all the Tonys and uh
I loved it so much and Andre the shields
who didn't play but he won the Tony
award and I like to watch his acceptance
speech because I find it
but he does because I went and saw a
Hamilton but then the guy who actually
plays Hamilton once they get too famous
somebody else you watch it hadestown
Bubba and you would it was good huh it's
better than good I love those places
better than good you would love it more
than anything Hamilton's
I loved Hamilton too though but but you
have to wrap every single [__] line
can I just get some normal dialogue do
we have to make this a hip musicals are
all music now it's really interesting
there's not a lot of story in the middle
of it
it's more it's just it's all the
non-stop rapping from the fat lady
selling this see I loved Hamilton but
you're a barbarian but I think he's tag
you would love really I like in general
I liked Hamilton I like it's just too
long well Hades town the musicians are
on stage so you watch I like that and
then you watch them and the way they put
it together and well the story is about
Hades it's it's the myth of when Orpheus
goes into the underworld to get yeah
you're ready to see he goes down to get
his girl his girl is hungry she goes
down to the Underworld for a job she
gets stuck down there she's in Hell
Haiti says I like her yeah he takes
Persephone he goes get out of here you
go you always go to the uh you go six
months a year to the to the other world
I want her you are you're always in the
arms of the sun I want her so he seduces
her and she sells her soul she's
a great singer yeah she was really this
one was really beautiful
but uh he says he's like a he's a he's
like an an angel kind of like kid he's
like really naive and he goes down to
the underworld to get her and Haiti says
okay you can have her but here's the
thing
you start walking she's going to be
behind you there she is you're just
beautiful yes you you you you you start
walking she's going to be behind you if
you turn around before you get to the
upper world
she's going to disappear she comes back
to me but trust me
and he turns around at the end
she can sing her ass off Jesus Christ
yes it's cool yeah she has a splash of
Asian in her right she looks you know
she's I think Latin and Asian she's
always from Heaven she can sing her ass
off
I'm going to say this I'm going to say
this we'll move on when I go watch
Broadway yeah Filipino oh there you go
Mexican too there you go
um did her birthday Saturday bro
that's your soulmate
she's 23. that's a young lady that's
young yeah that's young she's that good
though she's a killer what a killer on
Broadway when you see that writing when
you see that music when you see that
kind of performance you see that all
that [__] you're talking about a whole
different level and you and you forget
where the bar is when you're just doing
when I saw Billy Crystal I'm like oh I
saw his one-man play I was like oh yeah
oh yeah you're the greatest ever do it
you're on Saturday Night Live you've
hosted the Oscars six times four eight
different parts different bar
their levels the talent levels come down
because there's so many other you know
ways and sources to watch stuff right
you forget those guys forget those I
watch them like holy [__] he wrote all
of it and forget where the bar is you
forget where the bar is you forget what
real acting what real writing I mean
you're like like top high level [__]
he's been in Show Business for how long
it's like when I did David Spade's show
on uh economy Central I was a guest on
it like six times that every time I'm
like oh that's David Spade that's right
he's in one of the Glory Days Saturday
Night Live like his monologue I'll just
watched holy [__] you watch you watch
when you watch some dramas on Broadway
like like Jerusalem with Mark rylands or
any of those plays and you just go or
something like Tom stopper's place you
just go I mean I'm telling you man I
don't care who you are I don't care who
you are you watch those plays and you
just come out different yeah you're
different when you leave that that place
yeah I saw a different understanding I
saw I saw uh Scarlett Johansson in one
of those plays and not slow what's his
name he's the voice for uh
the UFC countdowns really famous actor
oh I know you're talking about uh
Perlman no uh that Ron's gonna do the
voices now no but um he's on a Showtime
show huge show massive show
massive you know you know who he is
Dexter
Lee Shriver it was him and Scarlett
Johansson together we have Shriver comes
from that that tradition yeah I was like
New York tradition New York actor yeah
they were good oh yeah that's a New York
actor right so good we've done a lot
Shakespeare he's done a lot yeah yeah
you know he cut his teeth on those
stages real [__] Off-Broadway Broadway
Sarah Jessica Parker all of those I was
watching I was watching Sarah Jessica
Parker and those people when they were
doing small Productions Kevin Spacey I
was watching that dude doing small
Productions way before he got famous
they all cut their teeth on the New York
stage and they were monsters especially
back then monsters you'd see they say
you'd be like holy and Scarlett
Johansson person what boner alert
theater did you say that in the theater
boner alert I don't know how to access
right when she walked on stage and went
boner boner and so they kicked me out so
but I did see about 20 minutes of it
yeah it's it's uh it's
it's really interesting like Jordan
Peterson says there's more truth in
fiction in great theater and great
literature than in non-fiction as in you
learn more about facts you learn more
about life through story than you do
through facts
sometimes write that [__] down sometimes
sometimes always sometimes buddy the
thing about pulling the trigger on this
saltwater tank for my birthday so it's
called a Red Sea tank salt water do you
see that I sent you some yeah yeah tank
whose tank was that that was in a school
there was a homeschool and this very
wealthy man is uh creating these home
schools everywhere I mean that's a and
he puts a fish tank in there now how big
was that fish tank what would that run
you uh I thought when you sent me that
uh in a bookcase it's in a bookcase yeah
the custom tank the filter that's
probably there's a whole room downstairs
yeah I know I I don't know what do you
think a hundred grand 50 Grand well way
more way more more than 100 Grand yeah
yeah what yeah that's like you showed
the thing you showed me like the tank
off of uh them show tanks yeah I mean I
would I don't know 500 Grand what are
you talking about what they said there's
a whole room downstairs that needs oh
yeah all the filters the sump tank all
that [__] something that I think it's
like Rick Ross has one nowhere near that
size but it's like a circular so you
know so fish can swim like this 700
Grand
uh Georgie sent me this this is from a
restaurant underground restaurant in La
it looks pretty damn dope I can't play
the music here it's called This is looks
like they have stingrays Mrs fish it's a
huge like it's all over the place and do
they get their fish out of there and eat
them hold on if you eat sushi yeah I eat
sushi I don't like that I do
and the fish are swimming around the
fish like that that's a bad ass [__] I'm
all over that it's super cool I mean I'm
sure your family would love to go there
too it's an ocean Oasis guys yeah that's
pretty cool though
yeah
I might get this Red Sea uh fish tank
if you have salty water it's a different
animal daddy you're stepping up in the
big leagues because if if a saltwater
fish dies you really it's expensive
probably five times the price of a
freshwater fish really so you're gonna
have all your [__] really all your
fishes so what are you prepared you're
prepared to spend drop some coin do you
need a saltwater tank I really want one
it's it's the evolution you go like
that's what I was talking to the guy
yesterday because fresh water starter
yeah he goes I knew you're gonna get to
this point he's like just the fish
you're buying already and how obsessed
you are like the evolution everyone goes
to salt water I was like yeah but
they're aggressive saltwater fish
you think the fresh water aggressive all
fish are having a hard time
trigger fish like puffers and you can
get stingrays sharks couple things
couple truths live Coral couple truths
one ninjas hate crunchy leaves yes two
all fish
all fish are having a hard time because
there's always something bigger that's
going to eat you oh those are those are
the two facts of life right well
yesterday we have you know we I got my
son a Nintendo switch we play uh Mario
as a family well even bossy plays Mario
but the fish tank is there with the big
arowanas I was like I need to feed them
I didn't think of it I was doing I got
anything so I have feeder fish because
they're they need to eat live like sure
food I just grabbed I didn't post it gin
I'm gonna have to go to it so I just
grabbed the net and I get like 20
goldfish put them in there 20 20 yeah
because there's like you know those big
monster fish in there I'm just playing I
heard joy and go oh my God I'm like what
she was that big fish is in the small
fish yeah baby Circle of Life what do
you think I was doing down here she's
like oh and he's going honk honk just
honk oh what is this heat oh he probably
ten of them oh Jesus how often do you
feed him uh once every three days live
fish
but I wasn't separate just for the
feeder fish damn so you have to have a
lot of feeder fish yeah you're always
replenishing I always do so if there's a
story two days there's a strike in the
fish store we got problems yeah
everybody dies yeah everybody dies
everybody so so pet stores are very
important to you how often are you at
the pet store three four times a week
too much too much too often oh yeah they
know my name I say what's up anything
new ah we got this flower and they got
all kinds of different animals
and then I was trying to kill time
because I got to my son's school early
I'm like you have another 30 minutes
fish fish store it's called aquarium
cities right up the street right off
Sherman Way there I might as well stop
see if they have any fish I'm just
moseying around kind of bored and the
guy goes you always look at that
saltwater tank I'm like man it's a beaut
it's the Ferrari of fish tanks
it costs a lot of money uh probably
three grand okay three grand it's like a
100 gallon tank that's manageable
with the sump and everything it's around
100 gallons but that doesn't cost you to
maintain there you see now you're asking
right questions because then the lights
like the the lights to that the coral
needs stay alive and like you have you
ever seen a solar tank how dope it looks
you have living Coral in there you have
living Coral you'd have like trigger
fish you'd have you know you can have
more your eels but the sump and
everything so I'd say all in it probably
five grand at the end of the day but you
I have to get it up and running that's
why I want to get it soon yes exactly
see how the coral is gorgeous the lights
alone are like 600 each and you need
that that special light that keeps
people are all alive yep God I love it
I'm actually looking into it yeah I'll
just stay up myself there's nothing
there's nothing more relaxing than
staring at the only thing that relaxes
me really only thing that relaxes me I
got problems no you don't I get it but
it's cool to watch man you know it's you
know it's um but you don't have to you
know you have to let the tank run for
about see that's sick you have to let
the things about six weeks just to get
it all pristine have it cycled make sure
everything's working and then drop in
the real fish I like that right there
what's that cause me uh oh three uh oh
man uh 50 60 grand 50 60 Grand that
coral and all that's expensive the
filters underneath see those lights
those lights just the one of them 600 uh
dollars a light so it's just that whole
set just the lighting up new maintenance
maintenance
you know what's you know what that's
cheaper than though everybody loves
horses oh yeah horses you could buy any
Ferrari in the world I remember I told
you all right we'll buy a Ferrari Brian
I said I said I go uh I'm paying this
much for the horses that my daughter and
my wife at the time
but then you have to you have to provide
housing for the horse you know you don't
have the house to keep it on your
property so it's like that no you got to
maintain the horse you gotta feed the
horse every day they gotta take care of
the horse I'm getting bad bills oh yeah
all that so all this adds up you I mean
you said I said six seven Grand a month
you were like it's less than that but
but it was like
I think it was 3 200 at one point it was
something crazy my my accountant called
me up and he goes are you a land baron
or a rock star because I'm just
wondering like you're gonna go broke
horses too expensive horses it's too
expensive and great I love them but yeah
unless you own like a property and by
the way I think it was I don't know how
much it was because I would stop looking
because it was too much I think that I
remember when you started starting at
32. yeah but I remember even got up
higher than I was like what are you
doing well I bought a horse yeah so we
have to add that yeah I got talked into
that I went I remember I said because I
don't know anything about it so what
they're doing is there I'm getting all
these these these things I have to do
horses get sick and I'm going I'm going
I know but but what a horse can't I buy
a horse for five thousand dollars to
[__] horse let's get a smaller horse
a baby or horse and then we'll just grow
it into something and I got this i got
this just like this is the this is the
Olympian
owner Pro everything so just ask me
questions about a horse
your horse is going to cost X amounts
crazy amount I'm not gonna say what it
is just now now try to make an argument
just ask me some questions about how we
can go cheaper go ahead well could we
like figure out a way for the horse
maybe a smaller horse maybe it's a
different color so I could save on
pricing no
that everything's no
no explanation no explanation I go so
you're telling me I know you're watching
a kid there too no I was on the phone
with him oh no I was like I know but I'm
saying but why does she need this horse
you know does it have to be a horse
that's this trained
yes
well because in that I can't go cheaper
no because in that line of work that
like think about the people that buy
those horses it's like your time I had
that Bentley I went to go change the oil
and they're like 2 800 I was like hold
on oh my God twenty hundred dollars for
[__] oil change and she goes look
judge says he goes yeah I went this is
stupid she goes if you're worried about
the oil price why would you you
shouldn't have a Bentley that's right
and I was like that's right you're right
sold it two days later yeah like oh no
doubt well also checklist at least with
your Bentley you can sell it now you're
not getting your money back from a [__]
is there not a used horse Market there
is but good luck and and yeah and then
when the horse is not being ridden you
gotta lease it
you see you can't leave a horse in the
stable horse got to be worked so you got
to work gotta work you gotta work gotta
gotta run it gotta exercise it gotta
train it and that takes huge well that's
a daily thing so and that would be
humans yeah so I don't know what it was
I don't want to talk about it no boat
boats are the horses are like boats you
don't wanna you don't own them so just
do a timeshare thing boats are another
thing boats where's investment you make
oh my God because remember because now
that boat can't sit in the water you
have to throw and lift up by the water
clean it dude that's right nightmare You
Gotta Have It cleaning constantly all
the time
it's a private jet right when you own a
private jet you might you have a lot of
money no problem you own a private gym
you have all the money here's the thing
so your gas is that's adorable you're
you want to fly across country
from LA to New York in a private jet
just you and your family okay we're
gonna start the oil the gas we're going
to start with uh it's going to start at
55 000 oh that's just it but that's just
in fuel but that's just in fuel not
killing a pilot yeah now the plane can't
sit on the ground though man you have a
pilot that pilot is actually a lot of
times you work how to deal with they
lease they are leasing your jet out to
other people somebody going back to L.A
gotta have it that's how you get your
money private jet different level yeah
if I'm Ryan Reynolds and I sold that my
company for 1.2 bills private
even then though I might just buy shares
on a jet I I just the idea of owning a
jet just feels a lot in it I just don't
doesn't well I just looked into it you
know because I hate flying I was like
yeah I wonder how much you'd fly private
to London when I go there in June don't
you think
Ellie from here to London well that's an
eight-hour flight Papa that's a nine
hour flight you know you're sniffing
around you're sniffing around for that
that's adorable because you're you're
talking about over a hundred thousand
dollars 175 Grand 175 one way one way
one way one way 175
000 what oh cool yeah I would I would
put you in a choke holder I would freak
out if you ever no I can't no nobody can
afford I mean I don't know I don't know
you can afford that if you got crazy
that's crazy money it's stupid I mean
that's I I have a problem with that fly
first class I'm sorry I'm gonna say this
I really mean this if I had that kind of
money I I I wouldn't do it I would feel
like God was watching I swear to God I
could give that money to someone who
really [__] needs it I would you need
to be that way no I'm I'm I believe in
it I believe in that we got you get me
off this
you selfish [__] I'm not 175 Grand get
out I didn't know it was even that much
I'll pay 30 grand for a crazy first
class ticket on United on something or
20 grand for a crazy first class ticket
but what's your guest just for eight
hours 15 grand that was my guess I was
15 grand you'd still be like 15 grand
the first class ticket 15 Grands first
class ticket to Australia yeah by the
way the horse thing I I don't know if I
talked about it before but I know I knew
someone that did just horseshoeing
literally just the horseshoeing he made
over six figures yeah just doing that
yeah
he's a skill set yeah horseshoeing is uh
I was just shy I paid for that I can
tell you that I paid for that I know all
about horses the song also has to melt
them big dicks well that's if it's a
stallion you gotta milk that day you
can't leave it full no you got to milk
them out do a weird job they do it
though oh yeah do they ever yeah
um so yeah it's a big job we're on a
group chat with uh Eric kristalia for
Golden hour Nick um so Chris posted
something about Diplo on a podcast with
that Emily I can't pronounce her name
because she's Eric on Andre's girl yeah
exactly so she's a daddy
Diplo mentioned that he doesn't identify
as gay right he said he might be a
little bit gay and he he does remember
he recalls he's being a little bit
pregnant isn't it he recalls the time he
had a [__] from a dude but then he's
like it's not that it's not gay if you
don't look in their eyes or something
like he's joking about that uh it says
the star who has only date women
publicly said I don't want to Define
that I'm sure I'm a guy before but I'm
not gay I really I'm not really aroused
by men that I know about I'm sure I've
gotten a [__] from a guy before now
here's this he goes on though if you say
I'm sure I have hey it's happened more
than once whoops who is that which one
oh so this is a video that I can't play
hold on just read this real quick wait
wait so hold on he played get him who is
Diplo he's a very famous DJ
[Music]
[Applause]
um the Stars revealed it uh
oh so he likes to watch men chopping
what are you gay but I think that's
pretty hot yeah we're chopping guys
we're chopping a guy is kind of sexy I
don't know if that's a thing that's
gonna send me over to the gay side
completely but they're pretty hot you
dude but I but like last night I was
alone in my in my house watching I can
show you my I can show you my YouTube
history search history I was watching
male strippers dance why oh because you
wanted to learn the dance stuff you're
in a movement you're not aroused by it
it would never be aroused by it no all
jokes aside you right no not Ross yeah
can you imagine if I kick off the show I
would never dude I'm no no dude I want
to kick it that's hot who is that girl
kissing so this is a video uh which we
can't play but this is a artist named
Pablo vittar and then this is Diplo the
artist is I guess is transsexual I'll
just play it I don't know what that
what's that guy what's that mean that's
a guy on the left no no no no I'm gonna
play it and you'll see Diplo kissing
this person hold on
not yet it's coming up boy so this one I
guess this person is transsexual
it's like the Lady Gaga she benched 400
pounds
I like that I mean I admire that I
admire that what I said I like this
Euphoria episode yeah yeah I don't uh
listen I kind of I kind of like that
Diplo is making out with that woman who
used to be a man
that's there's Pablo vitar I don't know
much about this person but uh yeah I
mean maybe she's trans the more
technology brings us closer to another
oh drag queen never mind just drag queen
oh drag queen oh so full-blown man
that's what it says here uh Brazilian
dress and By Night Yeah by day I guess
uh although that's what you'd call a
little bit gay right if I catch you
doing that transgender I'm like hey come
over here man yeah I mean I can see you
doing that I mean
you've done that yeah
yeah and I've done it exactly that way
too so here's the thing I mean I've
really kissed uh with back to Diplo like
uh no she's not transient or if he's not
transgender
back to dipo I mean I think Diplo likes
dicks dude it's all good I don't give a
[__] dude some people get so famous
where they have so many ideas I do it
seems to happen right
dude I think he climbed the Mount
Everest of hoes and was like I I'm gonna
try dude yeah maybe you get to a point
where you've won so hard at life that
you go I'm gonna kiss a guy it's like
when you Mark Zuckerberg you have all
the money in the world you have all the
cars he's like I guess I'm gonna try a
jet pack well Chris Stefano seems to be
doing it Chris I know what it is but
it's that was so funny on Rogan he goes
I might be gay yeah just let that sit
for a second
uh no no um
I would say that uh maybe you just
decide I have such a great feeling of
euphoria over everything he's a guy well
no no no I'm just not attracted behind
right so there's difference between
kissing a guy which is I used to be it's
a Ayahuasca drugs are flowing shrooms
like man look at you there's all these
hot chicks yeah it doesn't feel gay yeah
I can see getting caught up in that
moment like you know you're at like some
Brave or something I can get I feel like
I'd be like oh oh my God I did that
makes more like god dude how about we
made out that's insane I don't blame the
iOS whatever right but when to have
another man put his mouth on your wiener
and you bust in his mouth
he came to completion yeah that's so you
clearly you were turned on right I I'm
not gonna but it's a mouth of mouth no
not for me long hair it'd be tough for
me I'm not I just am not attracted to
men I'm not like I look at you good
looking
and that includes in fact even a
transgender woman man or a woman a
transgender woman I can my Spidey senses
can feel the X Y chromosome there's
something going on and now there's some
like that what's our Blair white shoes
on Rogan
who was a man but now as a woman like I
had no clue that she was transgender I'm
like Jesus Christ
smart like really hot and smart and then
Jay was like hey that's another one
there used to be a dude I don't give a
[__] he interviewed uh yeah that's
interesting
did you listen to it yeah
yeah looks like a girl yeah
yeah very girl very girly
yeah you have a problem with that Brian
yeah I mean yeah no problem with it I
mean red white and blue yeah blue balls
Daddy
yeah yeah okay yeah I can understand you
you helping her with that gun yeah
shooting it wrong
that's uh
that's going all the way
I mean I have friends straight who would
have sex with her
and want to have sex with her yeah he's
sitting right next to you
she's cute
yeah she's like super cute
but with Diplo yeah it's just different
if like some dudes you know doing it and
he's like you're almost there bro I'm
like oh god dude this is over technology
is getting us to the point see you keep
bringing up technology when we talk
about this and I think there's more to
the story I'm you keep going with
technology we don't know there's gonna
be no genders we don't know and that's
something that someone that's two male
mice
two male mice created an egg and and out
of the two male mice and put it in a
female like like and create an animal so
same-sex couples are going to be able to
have biological children eventually it's
just really weird so what they're gonna
have to use a female to uh produce the
baby I guess yeah they do that now Brian
it's called I'm having profound thoughts
about all this but you know how to know
you're gay you keep going back to
science no I go you go do a science
these days yeah hey
right quit saying the evolution of
science we're all going to be gay guys
this is science I I am not to be I'm not
held responsible for technology oh man
you can't control it if I ended up
getting my my dick sucked and this is
exactly what the Unabomber was warning
us about that's what he was warning
about you're not going to know if you're
gay that's what you're saying yeah
you're not going to know if you were gay
or straight and you might be a little
gay and then that's okay because then
that's a little straight is it a little
straight or is it a little gay that's
the question yeah it triggers me when
you keep going the technology for outing
your gayness I'm not gonna make out with
that
yeah that's that's somebody who's a man
dressed as a woman is not going to do it
for me no no I need a lot of estrogen
running through your body yeah
but you know I don't know you know you
know I'm telling you know I want I want
smaller hands
look if you're Thai and you have a small
stature
like fool me Daddy and give him a full
glass of red wine the the let's be
honest young man the young man I made
out with if I may go into the memory
bank the young man that I bub slapped
with deeply and was and danced with and
got a handful of [__] and balls and and
but but but I that I really stared into
that I really made a connection we got
lost in each other's eyes and I remember
this and I was dancing and kissing deep
and I mean you got to get in there deep
well we went what I'd call a phone with
a pee booth and I I reached down I I got
something going on that I had I kept
kissing it was a big kiss because you
didn't want to hurt her feelings didn't
want to hurt her feelings kept kissing
and then and then feigned a stomach ache
and ran away you think that didn't hurt
his feelings I'll say this I would be
lying
if I said I didn't still think about her
because she was so my type curvy little
Latin yeah he was your type she was a
curvy little Latin guy well not Lanka's
top it was a Thai boy
well no it's Thai boy curvy Thai boy
that you're into it might have been but
I believe probably a curvy look this is
what you're trying to do there's no
Latins yeah no this was in this was in
New York at Club USA oh this is in New
York City he had a tight braid a tight
adorable little braid that went down the
middle of his back no one gave it away
and he was about five foot five did the
Old Spice deodorant Give It Away uh you
know um when he was [__] my ass
[Laughter]
was when I went I think something's up
here something you know what I'm not
into this I'm not into this let it
finish because I want to be polite yeah
I don't hurt your feelings go ahead and
bust yeah you go ahead and busted
uh we talked about this off camera only
if I keep it a secret and I enjoyed it
that's it Ryan Reynolds he so he was a a
minority owner in mint mobile yeah who's
the majority but so I looked at minority
order a minority owner but then it was
like 20 20 25 20 or 25 which is a lot
you get 20 that's a lot to me yeah so
minority I was thinking like that's how
you really that's how you use your your
celebrity so they're sold to T-Mobile in
a it's looking like a 1.3 billion dollar
deal they're not sure exactly where
they're oh they're over 70 of that so
then he's one point likely making around
like around 100 something mil yeah he
won't be in the uh unemployment line for
long and I just started seeing him
mobile stuff like the last year it
wasn't even that long and then it was
Ryan Reynolds yeah you see him doing a
deal with like Wendy's and it was just a
matter of time this is gonna happen yeah
yeah he's making a ton of money for sure
and uh another guy that's making a ton
of money who might turn it down I didn't
know this but Pat McAfee oh yeah she had
120 million dollar deal with 30 mil a
year for four years wow and he might
walk away from that to do other deals
he's very good there's bigger deals out
there yeah he's very good and he's the
direct line to Aaron Rodgers Aaron
Rodgers will that was a big part of me
with him is that true yes why because
they're boys oh
I don't know him I was gonna do his
podcast a long time ago in Indiana I
remember I connect you with him yes and
then I skipped into it God you [__] up
I just didn't do it because I was I
think he want to do it on Thursday I was
getting in on a like that day I couldn't
make it it should have done whatever it
took yeah that's great well it seems
like I mean then you told me he's my boy
that's my guy I didn't know I didn't
know he was I thought he was just a guy
who wanted to do a podcast Indiana no
but I'm like I'm not gonna come in on a
Wednesday he does and then also remember
Pat started at Barstool that was a bar
stool guy so he's part of the Barstool
family shout out to Barstool that's how
smart Dave Portnoy is yeah he sees
Talent they gave him a deal when his
deal was up he's like I'm gonna do this
on my own I'm gonna build a studio in
Indiana so I went to a student in
Indiana probably the first year he left
wow he had a whole staff basketball
court doing this he's just a winner guys
like that are just Savage apparently
always bets on himself and he always
wins oh well you should he knows exactly
what is his uh what is that the podcast
about sports primarily it's not possible
he does a show like a straight up show
and then also odd but
um it's about football right yeah I'd
have to know I'd be a boring guest no no
no no no no you want it he's so fun yeah
yeah I can tell he's got a great sense
of humor
yeah and he asks like real questions to
people too so yeah he's legit uh there's
a quick sad one Bobby Caldwell you know
that song What You Won't Do for Love
he's
which I freaking love by the way I did a
cover too he's he was only 71 and he
died what happened yeah this is terrible
hey you guys don't know that song
no that's not it when I first heard him
I thought he was black I'd kiss her
girls who was a boy is that song that's
not the song she load up every bit of
71 not that old but also uh what else
you got here fine dude you know
um I can't play this video but I'm sure
you guys already know this video by now
I don't know I don't know so this is a
teacher's aid and apparently a student
was pissed off that they took his
Nintendo switch and he beat the [__] up
the teacher so I'll play this video for
you guys yeah I won't make the No No so
that's him dropping her right there
she's already knocked out oh he's
kicking her knocked her out he's a big
dude too he probably has Luigi's Mansion
on there now it looks like he's giving a
massage so the Advan the back of the
head that's where it gets crazy and look
at all these people the kid clearly has
severe problems mental issues for sure I
would choke that [__] out he's
17 years old too look at all the people
around though that that is that security
there hey you guys got to stop that
mother Jimmy knock the teacher out badly
um
yeah so they're gonna try him as an
adult they should try yeah he's a piece
of [__] I mean he's mentally just he's
[__] up so not an excuse though that's
not so you can't do that no you can't do
that regardless everything homeless
everything
killing kids killing people oh mentally
she's a woman also you attacked a woman
for something that's stupid also you
dumb [__] you're six for 300 pounds why
aren't you playing football get off the
goddamn Nintendo switch and get your fat
ass on the football field
another thing I noticed too about this
this is in Florida it's a school but
look at everyone they're like oh almost
all of them are like completely fat
heavy yeah nobody knows what's going on
man look at the police officer or the
security well the parts of this country
where that's very common people eat in a
form of Madden you gotta cuff that guy
that teacher is still out dude it was
does she win World beating yeah she's
she's I mean she's dangerous she seems
okay now but who knows what kind of
damage that is she got shut off and then
so here in the back of the head is so
dangerous so thankful she was granted a
protection against him ever coming near
her yeah so she had to do that hey
rewind it chin let me see how what she
gets knocked out from hit her head on
the ground the first time yeah when he
when he pushed her down that's when she
got off that
you see she's out right there oh my God
I think she might have just gone limp no
no no
also dude that if you get to apply that
same energy on the football field kid
you'd be gonna look at this [__] the
[__] Alabama
the lack of urgency from everything
exactly if you saw that we've been up
jump in like right away right oh hey hey
dude see that guy right there yeah hey
bro jump on that kid what the [__] are
you doing dummy it's more hits there
finally finally dummy choke him
now he's just lying there now he's just
he's frustrating chin it is super
frustrating but yeah anyway he's going
to be tried as an adult as he should oh
he's [__] uh okay this is just going
back to one of our other episodes like
we get taggedness a lot you remember you
guys are talking about the uh guillotine
so apparently this is an open weight Jiu
Jitsu match and look what happens here
that big boy gets him in a guild again
not just a guilty but watch
oh he's oh that is that's me and you
Brian
readjust it does it again it's really
dangerous yeah
well then he finally Taps this is open
weight absolute
okay so it is legit this was so this is
from skatesurf yes don't go low on a guy
like that and this is from Adam
mentality world he does a lot of memes
with the showboat this is super funny I
love him whoever he is thank you that's
black right now what's going on there he
goes
an arm bar is not gonna kill you
[Music]
I'm not gonna kill you
he's stupid right stupid
all right
uh this one this is from a while ago but
people started tagging us a lot in
because apparently you can see someone
that looks like Brian Cowan this is
Michael bisping's post when he finished
the movie called red Sonia God bism
looks great oh well first of all it's
Bisping count and Thompson girl wait
where is Brian Callan right here Brian
[__] you guys I don't want to look like
that I want to look like Michael looks
great yeah bisbane's crushing it wait
but also oh that's also I didn't get
that person like where's Brian at and
I'm like oh
who say I look like that
we're saying let's get a few tags I
don't want that tag [__] all you guys
what's he do for the movie he's like the
makeup I'm as tall as Michael that guy's
a lot shorter no just the ability me and
bisbing are exactly the same height I
might be even a little taller yeah about
the same right that is funny though and
then I got tagged a lot and finish this
one yeah I didn't know that there's an
odd like a like a wheelie pixelated odd
job in the the 007 game yeah if you get
really close but I got tagged a lot on
this because he does freaking look like
me his face identical yeah I would say
identical um yeah with my glasses off
for sure yeah
but oh yeah that was funny that's
hilarious and how about we
just do this real quick so Sydney
Sweeney who's from that Euphoria show I
believe uh so she teamed up with this
bikini line so I just thought I'd show
you guys bikinis everything my double
T's ever wanted that's who the article
is I thought she said can you scroll up
yeah I'll show you some stuff here yeah
I want to make sure that they're
comfortable yeah
she's she's impossibly gorgeous
incredibly hot she's real Brian she's
impossibly hot
that's her
oh wow I she was in uh White Lotus
was she yes and she's a great she's a
really good actress
yeah alrighty uh last one wow really
good actress
I saw I still follow Will Smith even
though I don't like what the stuff they
did but I still follow and I saw him
post this with this guy that does some
crazy Talent thing and I'll play it for
you real quick
[Applause]
it's just him with his hands and a pen
white people in the back
downtown
[Applause]
you know he's just doing this in high
school
I mean it's just a weird random talent
but it's so good well he's a drummer
well for sure
new and hobie's drummer yeah he's doing
he's able to do he's able to do four
things at once so everything
shut up okay shut he's the [__] up you
ruined the video
no but I mean he can do more with his
hands than he could with a drum set
drums they have two sticks yeah he's
just doing some crazy [__]
great fine Quest loves hot so that the
guy's name is instrumental
how is our boy Will Smith what's he
posting lately let's take a look Chris
Rock lit him up he is right
uh he's posting other people
ah interesting you just ignore it that's
what you should do just take it on the
chin take it on the chin run with it I
would
personally be like that was good I
deserve it
yeah I'd be like I'd rather you slap me
in the face than roast me like that dude
good job well job well done job well and
then move on and that's over and then
you're in Bad Boy seven you increase
yeah
yeah I think he's totally fine but it'll
be interesting that's amazing hey you're
gay huh what what's the takeaway from
this episode I think so and he got a
bully on your hands which we got to
figure out Gary the bully hopefully the
bully doesn't come to Tacoma next
Thursday Friday Saturday March 23rd
through 25th Tacoma Comedy Club come get
you some Tacoma and then I'm in Atlanta
April 13th through the 15th spoken April
27th 29th La Jolla Comedy Store just got
announced June 2nd through the 4th then
I'm headed on over the pond Belfast June
15th that's cool Manchester June 18th
London June 25th holiday October Dublin
June 25th get your tickets thinkboy.com
it's so perfect because I'm going to be
in Israel yeah if you need me I'll be in
Israel guys Levity Live come see me at
Levity Live uh March 16th to the 18th
and guess what magoobies Timonium
Maryland right 31. I like that club yep
and April from April one Friday Saturday
I'm there that's going to be fun all
right kids love you we're out what's up